foreign
Squad
too complicated
I'm sorry
uh
um
and that's
it
because there's there's a lot of aspects
that we've settled today
together with the leaders of European
countries and we're grateful for the
personal support
we've received a lot of assistance from
countries on this path of uh defined for
our independence
on the battlefield as well as the
financial support
uh
positive
um
I'd like to say also that today we had a
very fruitful discussions
negotiated on a number of aspects and uh
[Music]
some of the achievements of Ukraine and
uh
in the presence of the first lady of
Ukraine
decision in terms of uh the uh
the number of schools
and we are returning that thanks to our
Warriors
[Music]
together because the challenges are very
difficult and the same are for the
European countries
support one another and uh
we're all interested in the European
countries
electricity and this is uh this would
help the Society of the Indian countries
away
[Music]
which aspects are we interested in and
[Music]
a new name on this Valley of the brave
people and of course that would be the
name of the president of European
commission the resultant today
okay
many many things Mr President here for a
lot of India sorry I took the floor is
that okay yes it's okay many thanks for
that indeed it is now the third time
that I'm here thank you
um since the beginning of this atrocious
war and I must say it is impressive to
see how much has changed
to the better here in Keith life has
come back to Keith I saw people in the
streets starting their businesses again
you've told me how much more of the city
is Lively now and moving forward
I also want to congratulate you to your
military success
I know there needs to be consolidation
but still it is
but for all your friends too
and I want to thank you from the bottom
of my heart for the order I got today
it humbled me and it honors me and I
want to thank you for that because I
take it in the name of the millions and
millions of Europeans that support
Ukraine and I think it is a beautiful
symbol of the bond between Ukraine and
the European Union
yesterday we had the pleasure to host
the first lady in Strasbourg in the
European Parliament and it was touching
and heartwarming to see
the standing ovation with which she was
received and it was palpable the warmth
and the friendship in the room
to honor the first lady of Ukraine
we have discussed a lot of topics
first of all I must say the accession
process is well on track
it's impressive to see the speed the
determination the preciseness with which
you are progressing
um and as you know we support you
wherever we can
um I do not have to say to speed up the
process because you are speeding it up
that is very good
um in parallel we have agreed that we
need to work as much as possible to make
sure that Ukraine has more business
more income and thus the seamless access
to the European single Market is
possible for Ukraine we've done a lot
already indeed you mentioned the
electricity grid you might recall that
at the beginning of this atrocious War
there was still the plan that in 2024
the Ukrainian electricity grid should be
connected to the European one well we
made it in two weeks
this was amazing and since then
um even better Ukraine is delivering
electricity to the European Union this
we want to improve and increase and thus
create steadfast flows of income for
example for Ukraine but there are also
other topics where we can have this
seamless access to the single Market at
the moment being we have 98 of tariffs
that are no more on Goods that is good
but there are many non-tariff barriers
that we can take away and we where our
experts will work on we have discussed
that the roaming should be a permanent
and many uh different items that we can
work on so that we have a deep
integration of the Ukrainian
economy in the single Market the second
big topic of course was preparedness for
the winter the short term and here we
have earmarked already
150 million euros to make sure that the
internally displaced people here in
Ukraine have shelter
and I'm happy to announce that there
will be another 100 million to support
schools so that the damage is done by
the war in in those School schools can
be repaired in a short term
I know that 70 schools immediately need
the Reconstruction the repairing work to
do it's 70 000 children that can go to
school so this is an enormous motivation
for us also to be as fast as possible
that we make sure that we are prepared
for the winter it's with the children
and the education where the future
begins and therefore it is so important
we have been discussing of course the
budget support the so-called macro
financial assistance
um I'm very glad that today the European
Parliament now has voted positively on
the 5 billion loans and we are working
on the rest of the microfinancial
assistance the 5 billion can be
dispersed in the first tranche
mid-october so there's a clear path that
we have discussed together
the work on sanctions is also well on
track it is always important to exchange
with our friends in Ukraine the details
because we have to be very careful that
there are no loopholes there are no
circumventions and therefore
um there was an intense discussion mail
discussion mainly also by our experts on
what we can do together
finally a topic that is of utmost
importance also is the mid and long-term
reconstruction here we have discussed
how we can progress the structure the
platform for the Reconstruction and
we're both looking forward to having the
25th of October in Berlin a
reconstruction Congress where experts
from all over the world will discuss
what the best approach is for the
Reconstruction in an accountable
effective and Speedy manner for Ukraine
all in all intensive discussions on many
many topics but what I want to say at
the very end the evolutomia
we will never
be able to match the sacrifice that the
ukrainians are giving when they lose
their homes or they cry for their
beloved ones that have gone we will
never be able to compensate what you do
with your fight for democracy for
Humanity for the respect of the
international rule of law
but what we can tell you that you have
your European Friends by your side as
long as it takes and that we are friends
forever thank you for having me here
today thank you so much
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
we have followed yesterday your speech
your address uh State of the Union and
uh you said that you are going to
provide 100 million euro for skills that
is important to return our children back
home but at the same time I noticed that
he also said that the EU is going to
recognize a qualification of foreign
hookers it means also Ukrainian workers
and I as a citizen of Ukraine I afraid
that many ukrainians would have an
incentive to stay in the EU forever
Cedar that uh
as a kind of thread do you go into
counter it somehow to help those
ukrainians who are currently in the EU
to take a decision to go back home once
we win
yeah so first of all as you know uh from
the very beginning on we have
um agreed in the European Union on the
so-called temporary protection director
which gives all Ukrainian refugees that
came to the European Union immediate
access to schools to health care for
example Social Security to the labor
market to the housing market because in
that horrible situation these people
were in fleeing from home because of
Russia's bombs we wanted to help them as
much as possible
more than 8 million ukrainians since the
beginning of the war have come to the
European Union but the good news is on
both sides many many of them have
already gone back
so um around about 5 million have
already gone back to the to Ukraine
and that shows the most important part
we want of course to have our to give
our Ukrainian friends when they need
help as much support as possible
but we also know that they are longing
to go home again and build up Ukraine
and turn it into a prosperous country
and therefore the experience of the
European Union where there is free
movement for everybody is that is it is
a win-win situation for everyone who is
uh in this process and I think a living
proof is the fact that ukrainians are
coming home as soon as possible you see
it here in Keith to build up their
country again and what we do is support
business here in Ukraine and business
opportunities here in Ukraine as much as
possible
foreign
[Music]
of educational
infrastructure where our ukrainians can
come back their schools universities and
the also regions where we do not have
the reconstructed schools and where it
should be the online format of Education
uh and we understand if there is any
opportunity of renovation we have
already talked about this we need money
and I have already asked the Congress of
uh President Biden and to the European
commission uh the money which we need
this year and trenches which we'll meet
next year
are very keen on security
the average Sciences security and
but it is today for us
not a very fast solved question but it
is a priority we started these
conversations and we have positive
results
and with also German Partners we are
waiting for some systems and we are
getting none of them but we are waiting
for them and we are very thankful for
example
and it is quietly closing the question
of the lack of
ammunition and systems also we have
conversations with Germany Italy and
France and I have not received very
positive reaction from Israel
uh whatever it may be the countries
which can confirm us the protection of
our sky
we don't have a lot of them but there is
five of them and we will try to solve
the question within them and it is one
of the Urgent questions for our states
which will give us the ability to
believe for ukrainians in security
and
except for faith we need to give some
confirmations and we should not risk our
people but we believe in it and we want
it foreign
you mentioned the military's success of
Ukraine what did you expect from
European member states because Ukraine
asks for more Military Support uh what
will you do in your role to support that
and president zielinski
you mentioned the attacks on critical
infrastructure yesterday in your
hometown delivery
you also mentioned that other Ukrainian
politicians mentioned that Germany is
not doing enough what do you concretely
expect from Germany in the military
question
so to all the member states I recommend
it I don't even have to recommend
because we all share the same approach
that it is absolutely vital and
necessary to support Ukraine with the
military equipment they need to defend
themselves and they have proven that
they are able to do that if they are
well equipped so this is the general
recommendation to all member states the
European Union whose itself not
possessing any kind of military
equipment is facilitating this process
through the funding of the European
peace facility at its first and foremost
of course the member states
responsibility in a bilateral
relationship with Ukraine to go into the
details
[Music]
from the Russian Federation
we understand that there is no military
infrastructure but nevertheless it is
not a surprise for us that Russia is
hitting the civilian infrastructure
I have not understood this with the
question how can Germany help us but
whatever
uh I have just said to you that there is
a few countries that can give us the
systems and I'm very very glad and very
very grateful to Germany uh for their
systems and when we can facilitate this
process
we cannot count how it can be because
you can count how many civilian people
have died in Ukraine because of Russia
not because of Germany because Germany
helped us and uh
probably can give us their systems
faster but they are not hitting us with
bombs and Rockets
I want for every state who can give us
heavy military techniques from Germany
from United States and other European
States they know about this they open
this window and they open us this
ability to receive the heavier artillery
and heavy systems
I have once again very grateful to
everybody who give it to us
but I would like to emphasize that today
what happens in higher the region is a
positive action
due to the uh our armed forces and
because we have received quadratic
answers to our questions and it is very
important that every state will continue
to support us because what we want
with precise Technique we shall not know
how many ships or trains have arrived we
need a precise operations which has to
be underlined with precise weapons at
about the courage and cleverness of our
Armed Forces we see the results
so we are waiting for not only Germany
but for every country the contrativeness
nice help
thank you everybody and journalists our
meeting is over